well guys for better or for worse
alex jones
is now very very upset with me
uh it's hard to think of a bigger
endorsement than alex jones thinking
what i'm doing is very bad
alex jones devoting a a 12 minute
segment to me now four minutes was him
selling some kind of vitamin
so we're not gonna look at that but at
least eight minutes devoted to me
making me out to be a predator of some
kind
let's just jump right into this thing
this is truly beyond belief
let's take a look
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you thinks
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks pac-man never talked to
the new world order pac-man never got
tried to get hired by the kiss of your
group because pac-man's a loser is it
isn't this the absolute best thing i
mean it's it's wild
he's a sellout he's not a real man
and remember who did i sell out to they
never tell me
he's not a knight at the round table
that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate he didn't actually
have a real discussion with the power
structure he worships see i said no to
the evil power structure
not because i was a hero but because i
had god i had a connection to the
infinite i knew this was a failure this
was not good i didn't join with god and
justice because i was a good person i
did it because i had discernment and
wanted to be with god
and the still images of me to so that i
that are supposed to i guess be ominous
are pretty funny
sam cedar texted me let me tell you
exactly what sam sam's comment about
this was so funny um
he said it's really weird he does a
close-up of your face and tries to make
you seem evil but no offense you look
like a teenager from the neighborhood
who would carry an old lady's groceries
for her home from the supermarket and
yet and yet i'm made out to to look very
evil now what's really funny is i don't
even know why this clip triggered alex
jones so much it was one of the
voicemails i played
where people were saying
do you think if things got bad you'd be
able to get out of the country for some
reason it really triggered alex jones
so this is just a
snapshot of the bizarreness of acting
like a tape call is a call
and then nodding with it and talking to
it because you're so scared to actually
talk to people
now understand what alex jones is saying
he's saying
i'm when you guys know we do a voicemail
on every show when i do a voicemail i
say it's a voicemail i'm not pretending
it's a real call so alex jones is lying
to you that might come as a shock
he also says i don't take live calls on
the show we take a dozen live calls
every single week you i mean you guys
all know that we take live calls all the
time so the entire premise here is a lie
and give them the power of being live we
do it all the time that's what the left
always claims jones has fake callers
jones has fake reviews because they're
fake because they rig everything because
they're so scared they gotta control it
all
we we've been taking live calls every
week for a decade
and then to here cause we're gonna show
you the raspberries and poll okay so um
then he continues going into this stuff
and then he goes back to the personal
attacks which i have to tell you i find
them funnier than anything else so
they're doing this to us classical
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
collapsing and then he's talking about
them as victims talk about talk about a
fantasy talk about a simulation he's in
his own but he knows it's not a
simulation he loves this for his little
groveling followers that actually drink
this kool-aid oh that's an attack on you
guys he's talking about you guys
continue
yes uh but maybe some people in the
audience uh have a different perspective
on the bonus show today
we will talk about the five that's
enough oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad
there is no greater endorsement for the
bonus show than alex jones hating it
guys i can't think of a better
endorsement of everything we're doing
then the fact that alex jones hates it i
really can't
if i was telling my children who not to
be it's that guy i mean he's a disgrace
and i don't say that like god i feel
good about myself no he makes me feel
pathetic oh well that's interesting
that's uh i mean we should alex if if
seeing me makes him feel pathetic
that would be something to explore in
psychotherapy i think that that would i
think
psychoanalysis would have a lot to say
about that
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
so anyway that this is basically just an
unbelievable thing now a couple a couple
really funny things about this number
one
i only got two messages in response to
this
that's how diminished alex jones is
right now in the past if when he was on
real platforms
and he would do like a set you know
eight minute attack video it would
create a frenzy i got two messages
because
i don't know that anyone's watching alex
jones anymore secondly
i bet alex jones has no memory of the
fact that he and i
have met in person and we talked for
close to a half hour at the talker's new
media seminar some years ago alex jones
me
and the hosts of free talk live ian
freeman and mark edge
ian now i believe is is
under arrest
the four of us just had a completely
normal conversation about the business
of media
and
i'm sure he doesn't even remember that
but at the time he wasn't acting like i
gave off predator vibes
he seemed fine chatting with me and uh
i'm sure if you it probably made no
impression on him i mean listen who was
i to alex jones at the time but uh just
an interesting interesting little tidbit
but
an incredible endorsement when alex
jones is this upset with you uh you know
you know
that uh you must be doing something that
is resonating with at least some people
so there it is
um alex jones very unhappy with me we'll
have clips from this on our instagram
which you can find at davidpakmanshow
you can also find the clip on my
instagram at david.pacman
one of our long time sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20
off monk packs keto nut and seed bars
which taste just like your favorite
sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance monk pack
nut and seed bars become your favorite
go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout